you know every time I come here man I
Drive past the worst amusement park in
the world called the Holy Land okay so
I'm gonna go this weekend they better
sell sandals at that gift shop sandal it
look like this is real same from
Jerusalem
[Music]
I did say Santa yeah just two words
before the other yeah so they do some
sales what else is in the gift shop
is there a cartoon Jesus on the back of
the roads home come on what else they
got at the gift store Bibles yeah
Bibles of books sandals the robes worst
funky Oh Sam I know I was a kid and my
parents don't think we're going to relay
them to come on in the Holy Land I'd be
like you guys right now
one of the roller coasters in there -
lame
what's the attraction we're gonna see
when I get there
like what time shows that's what I
really wanna know now I really have to
joke because you know they're the worst
actors ever and I worked in a theme park
all of us were high all the time there
were some high Jews Andros pretend to be
Jesus signing me up I'm on board for
watching that all right and how much
does that mean it should be free to get
in I mean right it is the Holy Land
[Music]
how dare you charge me one of the
original members of the tribe they can
turn me no charge the Judas doing but
there doesn't work
[Music]
you